[Musique]
les journées partenariales de l'action
sociale se poursuivent tout ce mois
après l'ouest et dans l'est plus
précisément sur le champ de foire de
brapanon que les acteurs sociaux du
conseil départemental et leurs
partenaires se sont retrouvés autour de
plusieurs ateliers l'objectif étant de
mutualiser les dispositifs et surtout de
mieux comprendre les missions de
chacun les partenaires se sont impliqués
et engagé à inscrire en fait à élaborer
cet atelier là donc ce que nous on a
voulu mettre en avant c'est vraiment
valoriser le partenariat qui fonctionne
et et partir vers aussi d'autres actions
peut-être qui permettrai de mieux encore
mutualiser les moyens une consolidation
du partenariat qui permet de mobiliser
encore plus les dispositifs pour
répondre encore mieux au besoins des
personnes qui sont suivies occasion de
ces journées partenarial nous est donné
pour parler du dispositif Maya hein qui
est une méthode d'action pour
l'intégration des services de soins et
d'accompagnement dans le champ de
l'autonomie en fait tous les acteurs ici
présents sont soit acteurs du secteur
social du secteur médico-social ou du
secteur sanitaire et sont acteurs déjà
ou acteur potentiel du dispositif Maya
que nous présentons ici qui est un
positif de coordination gérontologique
pour répondre au mieux aux familles et
aux patients porteurs de maladies
neurodégénératives la Maya c'est un
dispositif qui découle du dernier plan
aalmer et qui consiste à fluidifier le
parcours des des personnes des personnes
atintes de maladies neurodégénérativ et
ma fonction gestionnaire de cas consiste
plus principalement à accompagn des
situations repérées comme complexes par
les partenaires tout au long de leur
parcours donc l'idée c'est sur ces
situations ben faciliter la prise en
charge et l'améliorer autre terme abordé
dans ces ateliers être parent
aujourd'hui l'occasion pour tous ces
partenaires qui travaillent ensemble
depuis 5 ans de se
rencontrer c'est un projet qui remonte à
2010 donc qui a vu le jour en 2010 avec
différents partenaires donc pendant 5
ans donc on a fédéré donc on a mutualisé
des partenaires autour de différentes
problématiques autour de la parentalité
autour de la de la personne l'estime de
soi autour de la femme autour de la
gestion budgétaire de l'adolescence donc
plusieurs plusieurs thématiques comme ça
donc carentalité aussi donc et
aujourd'hui c'était l'occasion en fait
de réunir tous ces partenaires de faire
un peu un bilan aussi les journées
partenariales mises en place par le
Conseil départemental offre aussi une
information à destination des
professionnels à l'image de Marie anque
assistante familiale sur
Saint-Benoît une journée que je pense
est très intéressante pour nous aussi
les assistantes familiales et ben convié
déjà ça prouve que nous faisons partie
du groupe et ça nous apporte beaucoup de
travailler avec les différents
partenaires et de savoir ce qui se passe
ailleurs les objectifs effectivement
restent les mêmes pour rappel ces
journées partenariat d'Action
Social sont des journnées consacrées en
fait à informer à permettre aux
professionnels de s'informer sur le
partenariat développé sur le terrain
donc par les
différents institution et acteurs qui
interviennent dans le champ du social
plusieurs ouvertures autour de thèmes
aussi divers que l'éducation la
citoyenneté la communication
bienveillante les neopsychologies ont pu
donner à parler et à échanger ils ont
aidé plus de 300 se retrouver à brapanon
rendez-vous le 23 septembre au tampon
pour la prochaine journée partenariale
de l'action
[Musique]
sociale I